I've probably put a hundred hours into
this game by now I don't have a problem
you have a problem Fire Emblem three
houses so fire rather than three houses
is the newest Fire Emblem game I'm a big
Fire Emblem fan I love turn-based
strategy games I just love them the math
the battle tactics is strategy yeah I
love it Fire Emblem three houses it's
like it's next-level it really generally
has everything you like from firearms
before except the whole triangle battle
system the triangle weapon system rather
so there was a system to it though it's
not really in here it's in here in the
sense that there are abilities you
unlock you can have these abilities
equipped to you and one of them is like
hey you're more powerful against axes if
you're attacking axes and you can have
that equipped if you'd like let the
sound of the customization the
customization this game is insane this
is all about how you train your students
students so we're just gonna get into it
the biggest and newest addition to Fire
Emblem three has a thing that sets it
apart is the fact that it's it's pretty
much Harry Potter there's a super
mythical school that trains students how
to be warriors or majors or archers or
whatever you play a character named by
life or whatever you want to name him or
her and they're like you know what
you're so intriguing we'll make you a
professor here so now you're totally not
the new Defense Against the Dark Arts
teacher but that's totally what it feels
like cuz you're at Hogwarts but it's not
Hogwarts this school called Garrick Mach
has three houses you can choose from
black eagles golden deer blue lion all
of which have unique students with very
unique personalities and you get to
choose which one you want to be the
professor up so now at the end of the
week you can go around you talk to
characters you talk to your class you
build relationships with them you tell
each student hey I think you'll be good
in this your training this sometimes
they want to sometimes they don't want
to and so they don't learn as quickly
early on and they might develop a taste
for the subject it's like alright now
they actually excel at that it's such a
genius move to push this franchise
towards this format I'm actually
surprised they didn't do it sooner color
because how could you pack all that into
a DS title but yeah like I said you
built faction with your class you give
them gifts you take them to tea just a
teacher giving his students gifts and
tea no red flags there at all as much as
it reminds me of Harry Potter
McGonigle looks a bit better I'm just
saying but I love just building the
relationships I love finding out about
these characters it's all completely
voiceovers it's not like you'd have to
lock in and read not that the voice work
is you know the greatest voice acting
I've ever heard and first
kind of thrown off of the fact that was
like I'm spending so much time in this
school training the students and talking
to the students finding items solving
mysteries solving puzzles planting crops
fishing there's fishing but even the
fishing isn't stupid sometimes you like
fishing minigame this one the fishings
not bad just like its you push a button
you cast the rail and now it's it's a
beet game essentially point is it's not
ball numbing lis cumbersome crafting
mechanics I'll never actually do because
it takes away from the games point and
direction and one of the things I like
with the school is that they move the
week along essentially it's at the
weekends funny enough of school that's
when stuff happens you have the option
of going in there and talking with the
students on school grounds you go out
there and do battles so that's when you
actually fight if someone wants to talk
with you during the week you can talk
with them but it's just this little icon
the sprite icons like alright and
getting to the end of the week cuz you
don't want to do this every day
what 365 days but when you're in the
school you have a limited amount of
resources to put into things and
activities you want to train yourself
you want to gain faction with your
students you want to gain faction with
other students you can then recruit into
your class I was the professor of the
Black Eagles class but even then you can
recruit students into your class that
aren't in your class which I suggest to
do because in my first playthrough I was
like I like my crew and I'm gonna I'm
gonna make them better at things and I'm
gonna improve my relationship with them
in the final battle it was like alright
so there's your crew and who do you got
to fill these spots it's a pretty big
battle huh yep I had no extra students
so here we go
that was actually a lot of fun because
was harder and that's just the school
element need to talk to your students
you need to build up their morale so
they learn better if you're not doing
that you're out there battling with your
students and if you like fire humble
before you're gonna like fire on them
now because it's what you know and love
from Fire Emblem generally some new
mechanics some new things they have
which I will say this game is kind of a
sand telling you how things work you
have to actually go into the menus and
figure it out yourself there is a menu
that's like oh hey tutorial training on
a bunch of stuff that I found later it's
almost like the games like here are some
tutorials yes wait you got it yeah
here's like left with your devices like
all right all right I'll play how I play
Fire Emblem there are a couple things
that are different one of them you get
these battalions these mercenaries or
whatever that you can hit people with
they do different stat nurse to your
enemy sometimes they'll just lock them
into
place they can't move I never really
used them though because if I'm using
them I'm not using the weapon if you're
not using the weapon I'm not getting
better with the weapon I never found a
reason to actually use them to actually
hit pretty hard early game but I'd
rather use the weapon but there was one
time I really was like I need them when
I fought the death knight for the first
time which was the second time I met the
death knight because the first time you
meet the death knight [ __ ] no if you hit
him with the battalion it doesn't
actually provoke a counter-attack and
that'll help you against the death
knight and when you level up a class or
get better with weapons you start
learning these abilities I didn't know
you can actually change these abilities
out didn't learn that until way later in
the game because it was like it said I
could do this why isn't it doing it so I
had to fish and find it yeah a bunch of
abilities I had and a few that were
equipped so after I swapped him out my
characters got a lot better but really
the customization of your characters
that's where did this game is crazy your
students are students so it's all about
how you want to train them what you want
to teach them it's like if you want
someone to be a paladin's they might
need a C in writing
being Lance I'm just throwing things out
there these probably are not the numbers
so if you meet those requirements you
give them the test to be a paladin to
upgrade and promote to a paladin it'll
show the probability of them passing
that test which if they meet the
requirements will be a hundred percent
they don't meet the requirements it
might be seven to nine percent might be
70% might be 50% they could still take
the test if they fail you're just out
the seal but then you just restart your
save and try again no shame this is an
RPG that's just called being smart but
if you have someone who's a thief and
you promote them to be an assassin it's
not like they can't ever be a thief when
you go into battle you can reclass them
they can become a thief again if you
want to max out the thief or you need a
thief for that mission I just love the
fact that when you promote somebody the
class they were is not lost forever they
can always go back to being that class
and based on how you want to train your
crude you can train anybody to really be
anything that the computer will allow
them to be there are a couple classes
that's like not only the male's can be
this only the females can be that a
couple of them but among teaching the
students and battling with the students
really it's just it's about the
connection you have with the characters
the characters become people you totally
don't want them to die out there in the
battlefield you're invested you care see
the relationship building and firing
them up to this point was always just
alright you fight better if you're
standing next to each other that's cool
maybe you'll crap out a kid and that kid
through some time [ __ ] can fight with
you that doesn't happen in here
really it's about the connections you
get with the characters it's about
finding out more about them and their
story the more they talk with you the
more you build that relationship this
was really the first game it wasn't
about the romance it was about the
connection with the characters hey they
know it's like if you're playing on
permadeath and someone dies you're just
gonna reset it anyway so you can reverse
time and you can reverse moves you know
all right I'm gonna go back and do that
differently you have a finite amount of
times you can actually do that but they
give you that option because they know
that reset buttons happening I played it
on permanent death and normal and I'll
say the game isn't as hard as some of
the Fire Emblem games I've played so if
you're a Fire Emblem veteran maybe you
want to play it on hard there was one
time at one time I had that james t kirk
moment where something big came out of
nowhere and we were all just staring it
in the face I felt like I let everybody
to their death I just turned to them and
be like I'm sorry I thought we were all
dead but we scraped and we fought and we
got out of it and we were high-fiving
digitally it's funny is one dude I know
he played a different class he didn't
play Black Eagles like I played but he's
so attached to his characters and I
can't imagine being more attached to
other characters than I am with the
characters in my class if you play Black
Eagles there's a moment where it's like
hey this will fundamentally change the
path of the game which one do you want
to do I'm really impressed with that
fork though it's like very few times in
a video game do you hear this is going
to fundamentally change the path of the
game and when you do it you're like I
believe that that's exactly what Wow and
the music in here oh my god the
soundtrack even the first battle of it
this is the introductory battle to the
battle system that music which is
actually the battle music for quite a
long time in the game is way more epic
than I ever thought it could ever be a
good soundtrack or at the very least
good battle music will set a game apart
from the rest and this one has great
battle music it's just great soundtrack
in general though this game is a lot of
battles so I guess a lot of it is battle
music because India and Fire Emblem
three houses it's everything I wanted
more it's more than I ever thought it
could be I was scared out of my mind
like our new Fire Emblem game they have
a lot to live up to oh my god I hope
it's good the epic Fire Emblem battle
style that I know and love deeper
character connections with this Fire
Emblem game than ever before intriguing
personal story and an epic grand story
and this is my favorite Fire Emblem game
it's not just good it's not just great
turn-based strategy Harry
Potter meets Game of Thrones is awesome
tacular Fire Emblem three houses 100
hours I'm still there after I'm done
with this video as it's uploaded I'm
playing it right now my sleep patterns
are completely [ __ ] you know how much
insomnia I had because of this game
first or second night I had this game it
was 11:30 in the morning I was like I
haven't slept yet well I haven't I slept
I'm not tired why do I not even want to
sleep I should want to I just want to
play this right so Fire Emblem three
houses have you played it what did you
think about it and what's your house
what house were you the professor or
what's your favorite turn-based strategy
game whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]